bref on va l'écouter son avenir ce qui
passe aussi par l'avenir de la planète
l'avenir de nos enfants ce soir je suis
triste évidemment de voir les résultats
non seulement en ce qui me concerne et
en voyant la poussée des radicalités est
donc évidemment c'est d'abord un
sentiment de tristesse que j'ai je
voudrais d'abord remercier mon équipe
qui est là tous ceux qui depuis que j'ai
présenté cette candidature avec mon
suppléant et christophe bouquet m'ont
soutenu ont permis de faire une belle
campagne une campagne que j'ai voulu
constructive bienveillante à l'image de
ce qu'a été la candidature d'emmanuel
hoog emmanuel macron en 2017 et en 2022
c'est à dire pour construire le futur
j'ai échoué à peu de voix 189 dans une
campagne qui a été émaillée d'incidents
où j'ai fait l'objet de violences
verbales très forte de la part de
beaucoup d'adversaires la plupart des
adversaires mais cette violence verbale
a même débouché sur la violence physique
à un moment donné
il y avait aussi des irrégularités de la
part du candidat qui arrive devant moi
au deuxième tour je regarderai
d'ailleurs juridiquement ce que l'on
doit penser de ceux là mais de façon
plus générale au-delà de cette
circonscription de 7 est du loiret du
montargois qui mérite l'attention de
tous les français parce que c'est un
territoire magnifique avec un potentiel
exceptionnel pour laquelle j'ai présenté
des projets qui à mon avis sont
représentatifs de ce qu'on peut faire
pour en finir avec le désert médical
pour en finir avec les difficultés en
matière d'emploi pour redorer la valeur
travail dans notre pays et puis plus
généralement pour avoir une posture
républicaine concrète face à tous les
défis de notre temps et notamment façon
radicalité
ce que je constate c'est que ces
pousse dans notre pays et que
malheureusement la digue démocratique
parfois semble s'effondrer je le dis
très solennellement l'extrême gauche est
un danger aussi important que l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui je le vis dans ma
chair depuis non seulement début de
cette campagne mais depuis cinq années
maintenant il y a une volonté de
détruire et il ya un danger et d'extrême
gauche comme de l'extrême droite qui
s'appelle hyper inflation chômage et
menaces sur la démocratie je le dis très
solennellement parce qu'il faut au 2e
tour au delà de cette circonscription
que nous réussissons le rebond
démocratique qui suppose d'avoir des
partis de gouvernement
mieux élu avec plus de voix au deuxième
tour qu'au premier tour c'est évidemment
ce qui guidera mon positionnement de
manière générale pour le loiret comme
comme pour la france
merci à mes électeurs merci à tous ceux
que j'ai rencontrés au cours de cette
campagne qui ont été si chaleureux
qu'ils soient des adversaires ou pas
mais neuf fois sur 10 a été très
respectueux très constructif je remercie
les habitants du montargois et je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup à faire ici encore et
que ça passe par une attitude
démocratique de bienveillance des ti
libre de recherche de l'harmonie parce
que c'est ce dont nous avons besoin pour
la france et pour nos enfants il est
tellement facile d'appuyer sur les
colères c'est ce que font l'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite nous devons
appuyer sur la république et sur la
démocratie je vous remercie
[Musique]